and brian we all remember as if it was
just yesterday how the strip looked
without
any visitors to put things into
perspective visitation numbers in 2019
showed las vegas hosted
42 and a half million visitors last year
barely 19 million sally jaramillo live
on the las vegas strip and sally
you've got a look at how 2021 could look
denise many people i spoke to today they
tell me they are
ready for vegas to return to what it
used to be
the entertainment capital of the world
whether that is shows concerts nightlife
conventions the news of people being
vaccinated
brings a positive outlook on our
visitation
things are looking better absolutely
come visit vegas going out is going to
be so much more special and we're all
going to appreciate it a little bit more
there is a new sign of energy on the
strip there's real pent-up demand for
travel
and there's pent-up demand for the las
vegas experience
lori nelson craft from the lvcva says
las vegas
is the world leading destination and
while it's been a difficult year it's
also been one of innovation
now what you're looking at is the
opportunity for travel to
really reopen for people to really start
planning their vacations
while it's going to take some time to
recover you're going to start seeing
more visitation as each month goes by
joseph saint-germain is visiting from
alaska he feels comfortable
traveling again it was a reward for work
we did a good job at work and they sent
us to vegas jermaine is looking forward
to comedy shows and conventions
today we just learned really exciting
news that
informal markets their world of concrete
show scheduled for june 8th through the
10th
just received their approval besides
world of concrete
10 other live trade events are planning
a return this year
we just launched a new business campaign
for the convention industry called fast
forward
and we are out promoting the entire
destination
i don't know what the normal is going to
look like at the end of the year
but i mean as you can see people are
they want to get out and they want to
want to do stuff
i do think we do need to be
still cautious of everything with the
pandemic but it is good to see things
open
now a national ad campaign will be
released next month another plan is for
influencers to come visit las vegas
so that they can share their experiences
with their followers reporting live
sally jaramillo
8 news now